Hola pues sin duda este tema energético
es de los principales que se abordaron
en efecto el presidente López Obrador se
dijo abierto al diálogo al diálogo con
las empresas del sector eléctrico que
están inconformes con las políticas
energéticas de su gobierno dijo que es
natural que se den estas diferencias
pero que se van a resolver de hecho cito
una importante inversión de la empresa
transcanada en un gasoducto en el golfo
de México para proveer de gas natural a
toda la parte del sureste también se
abordaron los temas de derechos humanos
de empoderamiento de la mujer y de
respeto a los pueblos indígenas de hecho
se firmó un memorando de entendimiento
los cancilleres con los presidentes y el
primer presidente López Obrador y el
Primer Ministro crudo como testigos de
honor para colaborar en materia de
respeto a la a los pueblos originarios
así fueron los temas que marcaron esta
agenda que fue pues muy fraterna en el
respeto mutuo se hizo patente en esta
relación esta relación bilateral México
Canadá ahora Mario Cuáles fueron las
conclusiones principales de esta cumbre
de los líderes de América del Norte que
también tuvo la participación del
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
Sí yo creo que habría que destacar en
tres rubros el primero sería en materia
económica se acordó pues diseñar una
estrategia para sustituir las
importaciones de Asia y que se produzca
aquí en el que Norteamérica lo que se
consume en esta región también en tema
migratorio con la participación del
presidente biden se acordó diseñar un
espacio para refugiados en México no en
cuanto a control migratorio sino para
brindar protección para otorgar
servicios de empleo de movilidad laboral
y otro punto sería sin duda el de el
tráfico de drogas se acordó reforzar la
colaboración para
intercambiar datos de precursores
químicos con los que se elaboran las
drogas y frenar sobre todo el tráfico de
fentanilo con un enfoque también de
salud pública